35 millones de personas que ya han sido
desplazadas por la violencia dentro del
país más de medio millón desde
principios de este año qué pasará con
ellos ahora que se sabrán los
enfrentamientos y que el talibán domina
el país podrán volver a sus casas todos
ellos dependen de programas humanitarios
que no dan abasto
así es la situación de la gente que está
dentro del país desplazada una y otra
vez es uno de los focos de preocupación
en este mundo también para nosotros
seguimos llevando ayuda humanitaria de
urgencia de ese medio millón nuevos
desplazados en 2021 el 80% son además
mujeres y niñas y seguimos viendo una
alta población en situación de riesgo
que son pues todas aquellas personas que
han estado trabajando con equipos
extranjeros con organizaciones
internacionales con organismos de
defensa militares etcétera y bueno pues
en este momento están realmente en una
situación escondidos o bueno pues con
alto alto riesgo para su vida es muy
importante que no nos olvidemos de estas
personas que están dentro del país y
para ellos en concreto es para los que
estamos en este momento
bueno pues poniendo todo nuestro
nuestros objetivos y nuestro interés
junto con el equipo de naciones unidas y
para quienes ya están huyendo del país
puede la comunidad internacional
garantizar que se respete el derecho a
buscar internacional en países como los
europeos por ejemplo la mayoría de
refugiados buscan además ayuda en
pakistán y en irán cómo se pueden
repartir las cargas con otras naciones
bueno efectivamente estás dando en el
clavo aparte de estas personas que están
siendo evacuadas que son una mínima
parte de la gente que necesita
protección lo que hemos hecho un
llamamiento desde acnur es para que se
dejen las fronteras abiertas
pakistán y dan acogen al 90% de la
población refugiada ghana que son
26 millones de personas en todo el mundo
y aunque el flujo de personas que están
saliendo del país es pequeño todavía o
sea no estamos viendo grandes cifras es
cierto que en este momento es muy
difícil atravesar fronteras pedimos por
favor a todos los países que echen una
mano que compartan esta responsabilidad
de proteger estos países han hecho a lo
largo de muchas décadas cuatro décadas
de conflictos en afganistán y de salidas
mucho por acoger dentro de su territorio
y dar bueno pues cobijo y protección a
estas personas pero pedimos también esto
a todos los países y desde luego las
fronteras europeas no son una excepción
en cuanto a que se abra a la posibilidad
de pedir asilo a refugiados afganos a
personas que están en este momento en de
protección internacional pese a las
dificultades que hay para atravesar como
digo fronteras internacionales maría
jesús cuáles son las soluciones a largo
plazo es realista por ejemplo la idea
que se está planteando de una zona
segura de la onu en afganistán
bueno va a haber que hacer distintos
escenarios el escenario de trabajo
dentro del país nosotros lo estamos
barajando al mismo tiempo estamos en
preparación con planes de contingencia
en los países limítrofes pakistán e irán
que ha sido los tradicionalmente
acogedores de refugiados ahí hay que
trabajar también para que estos países
no continúen siendo los que más presión
acogen y si los tienen que por lo menos
tengan recursos económicos para poder
responder al mismo tiempo los programas
de reasentamiento que son esas esos
traslados desde primeros países de asilo
de refugiados que se encuentran en
situación complicada vulnerable
incluyendo pues mujeres niños o personas
con dolencias o con problemas médicos
hacia países seguros esos programas
también necesitan un refuerzo del año
pasado por ejemplo pues del millón
cuatrocientos mil refugiados que
teníamos identificados desde acnur como
en necesidad de reasentamiento solamente
llegaron a países seguros 32 mil así que
hay que trabajar en todos los frentes y
ahí seguimos trabajando nosotros con los
equipos en el país y seguiremos mientras
bueno pues el acceso esta población y
las condiciones de seguridad nos lo
permitan a pesar de toda esta situación
tan tan durísima que se está viviendo